>> Alright, let's do a little quiz.
>> Okay.
>> To help us to kind of, make sense of the
equations in the Q learning equation by looking at a simpler case.
So let's imagine that we got some variable V and some
sequencing value X and a sequence of learning rates, alpha sub t.
So we're going to draw a series of these X values and
use them to update the V values and the learning rate is
changing over time and the learning rate is going to have,
first of all X is going to be drawn X sub T. Is
going to be drawn from some, the distribution of some random variable, big X.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And the learning rates are going to
satisfy two properties. One is that the
sum of the learning rates, summed up to infinity. But, the sum of the squares
of the learning rate, as we go to infinity, sums up to something less than
infinity. So can, can you think of
a learning rate sequence that has that property?
>> So, the one that I remember is alpha sub t equals one over t.
>> Good. So in
fact these's a whole range of possible powers
of t that work here, but one over t
is a good one. Why is this, why does it satisfy the properties? Well, if you sum
up the values up to sum value t, sum up the one over i values, it actually
acts like the natural logarithm. And so, as
t goes to infinity, the sum goes to infinity.
>> But logarithmically.
>> Which is still you know, infinity.
>> Yeah.
>> But if you look at the sums of the squares,
that's actually a well known problem called the I think,
the Basil problem, the Basil problem? And it turns out
to actually be pie squared over six which is kind of
crazy. But there it is which is a finite value.
>> That's intuitively obvious even to the most casual observer.
>> No I really, this, it's, it's, it's whacky. It was
an open problem for a long time and then it was
finally solved. And it's like, yeah sure pi squared over six.
Like where's the pi in here? There's no pi in here.
>> Mm, I didn't find pi anywhere.
>> [LAUGH] That's neither here nor there. The whole, the point
is there's, there's a bunch of sequences of learning rates that satisfy
this property, and we're going to imagine that we have a sequence
of learning rates that satisfies this property. We're going to be updating V
sub-t, with a series of X values drawn from, from distribution
big X, and what I'm asking is, what do you think this
converges to? Do you think it converges to the expected value
of X? Do you think maybe it just doesn't converge at all?
Do you think it converges to the variance of
X? Of, of the random variable X? Or does it
converge to infinity, it just keeps growing without bound?
All right. Does that seem like a well formed question?
>> sure.
>> All right. So let's give you a chance to think about it.
>> Okay.